the new range rover sport since people
seldom actually take it off-road
land rover has concentrated on making
the vehicle better on the road itself
we'll be testing it here at a small
airfield in minor target
first sasha drives slalom through a
series of traffic cones
but before we test the chassis let's see
how the design has changed
the youngest generation of the range
rover sport has a powerful dynamic
appearance
compared with its predecessor its
wheelbase has increased by almost
18 centimeters and the car itself is
almost six centimeters longer
short overhangs improve the aerodynamics
the interior boasts well-crafted
high-quality materials
lots of carbon fiber polished aluminium
and
leather give the british car a sporty
luxurious look
and now the slalom through the traffic
cones the new range rover sport is built
entirely of aluminium
making it 420 kilograms lighter than its
predecessor
this radical diet means the suv runs
relatively dynamically and sportily on
the road
even though it still weighs more than
two tons
the air suspended chassis now has
stiffer bearings and larger stabilizers
a noticeable improvement when making
rapid maneuvers
the new range rover sport took the
obstacle course with such sporty dynamic
ease that sasha says its handling has
caught up with the porsche cayenne
and the bmw x5
the three liter diesel engine in our car
accelerates it from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in 7.2 seconds
the engine's 215 kilowatts give the suv
an electronically limited top speed of
210 kilometers an hour
the manufacturer rates its co2 emissions
at 199 grams per kilometer
that's high but acceptable when compared
with other suvs
a hybrid driven version is in the works
and expected to reduce fuel consumption
to 5 liters per 100 kilometers
we'll see
this is a range rover we've seen how the
range rover sport performs on the road
but now sasha wants to see what it can
do off-road
a little test track has been set up it
is very narrow
sasha shows how it damaged a previously
tested sports wheel rim
to avoid damaging the new car we'll use
the old ones
to stay on the safe side our tester has
brought in a professional
instructor thomas capelli he'll take the
car through the test track
explains that we'll deal with the
narrowness of the course by using the
camera system
the range rover sport has five cameras
the car can be guided with centimeter
close precision using the two outside
mirror cameras
that takes some getting used to but the
driver can see how the wheels respond
to every movement of the steering wheel
but the cameras give the driver complete
control
and good control is crucial when driving
off-road
patience and precision are how you avoid
damage
next comes a real test of the range
rover sports stamina
the heavy burden on the left front and
right rear
the left rear and right front bear
little or no weight
putting tremendous torsion and pressure
on the body
but that is all compensated and right
and left
front and back are all crosswise
decompressed
the wheels briefly spin the system
strain and the vehicle keeps moving
showing that it can manage off-road
conditions well as the instructor says
anyone can let a wheel drop half a meter
to hit the ground but it's nice when
that doesn't shake you up inside the car
the range rover sport is now available
from german dealers
for now three different engines are on
offer two diesels and a five liter v8
gasoline engine
sasha says the starting price of the new
range rover sport is 25 000 euros lower
than for its predecessor
down to 60 000 but if you want a v8
compressor engine
that will cost you 88 000 euros a few
extras soon put you over 100 000 euros
so
most people will have to think twice
about whether they can afford it
the third member of the lyon family the
new sea at leon st
combines dynamic design with precise
performance and
high use value the sports tourer comes
with a choice of two gasoline and three
diesel engines ranging from 63
to 135 kilowatts the chic
sports station wagon has it all comfort
fun driving and lots of room
it'll be available in europe from the
end of november
ford europe has offered an exclusive
glimpse of the future
for example further development of the
parking assistant means drivers can get
out and let their cars park themselves
using wireless technology cars can
exchange information about the traffic
situation
and warn each other of hazards ford has
also presented a system
for automatically avoiding obstacles
it's been a long time since golf gtis
had to buy with opal mantas for the
hearts of boy racers
only one of the two models has survived
and now it's fresher than ever
37 years after it was first introduced
volkswagen has unveiled its most
powerful gti to date
drive it tests the gti performance to
see just how much muscle
it really packs
the gti performance has 230 horsepower
and that gives it a 10 horsepower edge
over the standard gti says reviewer
there's fantastic acceleration and
pulling power
there's also an active limited slip
differential that makes a big difference
in traction
especially when cornering in short the
gti
is fun the 4-cylinder 2-liter petrol
engine is turbocharged for extra punch
it does 0-100 kilometers an hour in 6.4
seconds and produces a maximal torque of
350 newton meters
says that's one of many design elements
making this gti stand out from the
standard product
the characteristic rims aggressive sill
and the red lining in the radiator
grille all
add to the overall powerful effect the
many gti badges have
more to do with tradition
the gti passed the moose test with
flying colours thanks to its bite and
agility
the driver is in control all the time
here he needs only 34 meters breaking
space from 100 kilometers an hour
and it doesn't take him long to get back
up to speed either
the upholstery has the typical check
pattern with red stitching
it's exactly what you would expect from
a gti interior
as in the golf ball gear knob there's
plenty of space also in the trunk
the six gear manual shift did well on
the ecological front we measured fuel
consumption of 6.5 liters of super per
100 kilometers
although volkswagen claim only six
liters for the same distance
our findings mean 180 grams of co2 per
kilometer
and the clean exhaust wins additional
points for the car
the gti performance costs 29 825 euros
with manual shift
and brita says that's a fair price for a
car with such powerful performance
sporty design and extras it's your
decision
whether the gti image suits you
bmw added the gt to its upper medium
class 5 series in 2009
now the company has sold more than a
million of the sixth generation five
series
it's given the range a facelift the
improvements aren't just superficial
the gran turismo is more high-tech too
but
is it really a hatchback in the classic
sense
drive it tests the most extravagant 5
series model
bmw's frank emmanuel agrees that the
5-series gt
isn't necessarily comparable to the
hatchback limousines of the past
actually it takes the best of various
car types it's a four-door limousine
but like the x5 it has a raised seating
position which gives you a better
overview of the traffic and it's packed
into a coupe-like
elegant form
we're testing the 535ix drive the
smaller of the two petrol models on
offer
the six-cylinder engine produces a
maximum torque of 400 newton meters and
delivers 225 kilowatts of power
it's on sale for 62 300 euros in germany
the bottom of the range 135 kilowatt
diesel can be had for less than
50 000 euros
says the 5 series navigation system
comes with a touchpad
which recognizes letters as you trace
them with your finger
first choose destination and enter
a new destination
the computer
you can talk and keep your hands on the
wheel you drive and talk to someone as
if you were talking to someone next to
you
says the good thing about the 5-series
gran turismo is its versatility
you can move the rear seat back and
forward you can adjust the rear seat
armrest
and that all means there's a lot more
space in the trunk
in fact there's between 500 and 1700
liters of storage space
so at a pinch it has more space than the
5 series station wagon
bmw's frank emanuel says this is a car
conceived for long journeys like the
name says
gran turismo there's a lot of space in
the interior especially at the back
the materials used are high quality so
it offers quite a luxury setting
it's a car designed for a certain taste
and a particular kind of customer
so the number of vehicles produced is
naturally not very large
so it's a car for demanding and
extravagant customers
says the interior of the graniturismo is
a very different one from the normal 5
series
including the dashboard and the whole
front it's a lot more
curved the middle console is wider than
in the normal 5 series
there's an issue with being able to see
out the back
you can hardly see anything from the
front due to the rising shoulder line
and the narrow window at the rear
so parking backwards without a camera is
a challenge
there are things he likes and things he
doesn't like about the five series gran
turismo
just like with any other car he likes
the dashboard and the central console
and the way the car drives
he doesn't like the way it looks from
behind but then again
he can't see that when he's driving
is passionate about classic english
sports cars
here in a small back garage in munich is
his greatest treasure
an mgtc ten thousand of them were
originally produced
says that that's a relatively large
number of vehicles
they were built in various types and
versions but technically they were
basically the same
the car has four drum brakes situated
here
which have to be adjusted manually you
have to tinker around a bit
the front and back axles are attached
with leaf springs
that's a bit unstable and you notice it
on the curves
shows us where the tank and the spare
tires are at the back
he says the car has lever arm shock
absorbers which are typically
english and they need to be constantly
filled with oil
the mgtc was launched shortly after the
end of world war
ii and is the most spartan mg of the
t-series
with its long hood separate fenders low
doors and compact trunk
it looks like a classic 1930s english
roadster
describes the bodywork which is made of
wood and steel plating
the body shell is assembled around an
ash wood frame
he says even the door has an ash wood
frame with steel body panels nailed into
it
and then
enjoys every minute in the tc it only
weighs 820 kilograms
he's willing to put up with a bit of a
bumpy ride in exchange for a thrilling
driving experience
he says the joys of driving an mg tc are
having the wind blowing in your face
and the way you're in control of the
vehicle
there are no electronics and there's no
heating
you're really close to nature and have
the feeling that you're fighting the
elements
technical as well as natural elements
he says he's bored by modern cars
the direct steering takes some getting
used to and sometimes driving the tc
feels like riding a
bucking bronco
but he says he's got used to feeling the
uneven road surfaces
he just holds on tight and bumps along
you can reach speeds of up to 125
kilometers an hour with the 1250cc
engine it's good for 54 horsepower
back in his garage he checks the engine
compartment in the past it wasn't
possible to seal engines well
classic cars frequently suffer from
small oil leaks
says it's time to get the original oil
cap fixed so he's going to swap it for
his
bathtub plug in the meantime the plug
fits relatively well and
should seal it pretty well
began some 50 years ago
he says he first saw the mgtc in 1963
and was completely bowled over by the
shape of the car
the big 19-inch wheels and the
rectilinear form
he says it's a car that is rarely seen
on the road but still has a sporty look
found his mg in norway and spent a lot
of money and time restoring it
he drives the car almost every day when
the weather is pleasant and
sometimes even in winter too
it's important he's clocked up more than
500 000 kilometers in his mgtc
he says and has changed the pistons only
once
that for many people the car is not
suitable for everyday driving he says
is because it requires a lot of
attention the radiator has to be kept
full
and it's best to keep the car in a
garage
but if you have an aptitude for
tinkering around with cars the mgtc
can become a friend for life that was
the case for les brestida
and before him for stars like clark
gable and
formula one world champion phil hill
so
you